so I want to give a shout out to Conor
McGregor because I think there's
something all of us can learn from what
Conor just did this last week that is
very very very difficult to do very
difficult to do and Conor did it let me
explain to what it is I am right now in
Miami
real nice here we got a couple business
things we got to do but let me get right
into my message with Connor so Connor
fights cowboy Cerrone this past week
commanding when 40 seconds I'm a fan of
cowboy but Connor came out it was done
deal and right after bad with the
shoulder thing that he did a bunch of
memes Snoop Dogg had the best meme all
these things go crazy and everyone's
talking Conor McGregor but people are
not paying attention to the biggest
thing let me explain to us the biggest
thing here's a guy that went from zero
to made a hundred and ten million
dollars in a year in 2018 then he comes
out with a brand called proper twelve
that's now a UFC MMA sponsor and he's
taking pictures with it and everybody
around the world is behind this proper
12 now whiskey he's killing it he's on
top of the world every talk show wants
him every TV show wants him everybody
wants him to do a cameo everybody wants
him to say a couple words every year SP
and show everybody wants this guy 2030
million followers Instagram Twitter
Facebook all of these people and he
still shows up to win the fight still
shows up to win the fight and in the
postgame interview I'm more of a fan of
a postgame interview than defy matter of
fact the postgame interview was better
than the fight let me explain to you why
in the postgame interview the guy asked
him a question he says so you know were
you got right now what happened with the
last fight against khabib you know what
would you say about what happened was
your last fighting could be be says you
know I disrespected my team with the
last fight with khabib what do you mean
you disrespected here's what I mean by i
disrespected he says my training camp
everybody that I had hired I'd go in and
train for an hour they wouldn't see me
for three days
these are people that are trying to
prepare me to win and go up against
khabib that's undefeated and I
disrespected them I disrespected my
training camp what do you mean you
disrespect to your training camp you
worth 100 million dollars the people
you're hiring to work with you they're
not worth that kind of money
this guy's publicly saying I insulted my
team who wouldn't want to work with a
guy like this at this phase right but
the biggest thing that's so obvious to
take away from this guy's fight is to
know that you have this level of victory
you're on top of the world you have
money in the bank you got the cars
everybody around the world knows who you
are and you still come and put on a show
and you still want to come back up
whether it's fighting you smile whether
it's Maz Vidal whether it's Kobe
Covington you're coming up to want to
fight those guys after you got paid more
money than every MMA fighter combined
you got paid more money than all these
guys combined pretty much and you still
are that hungry here's a question for
you to those of you guys that are
winning and starting to make money you
know what's the first thing that goes
when you make money training discipline
gratitude reading improving getting
better blind spots all of that Ghost all
of those become your blind spots because
you think you're on top of the world you
think you're invincible I watch a
documentary with Aaron Hernandez in the
documentary Bill Belichick they show
clip of him talking to his team he says
all it takes is one mistake one mistake
can cost us a championship one mistake
will cost us a championship all it takes
is one mistake when you're coming up I'm
not talking about calls all this other
stuff but when you get to the top and
you start experiencing some success Oh
Pat let me tell you I'm gonna make a
million dollar your income I'm gonna
build the next billion-dollar company
I'm gonna go the next ten million dollar
company and you're making 100 grand a
year right now you don't even know what
it is $10 half a million dollar even
come what are you gonna do when he can
make $500,000 your income you can go to
any restaurant any place drive a nice
car to live in a nice place and what are
you gonna do to get out of bed when
you're making a million dollar income
we're two million dollars or five
million dollars or ten million dollar
income or a hundred and eight million
dollars a year how do you get out of bed
that's what Conner did that's why he
respect a guy like that that after he
made 100 million after he's got proper
twelve after all these accolades after
being well-known worldwide he still
comes out the gate and shows a fight now
no one knows what he's gonna do next
but for all I know he can go and throw
another thing through a bus and fight
another person and get arrested and get
six to 12 months but I respect the fact
that he sounds like he's being very
transparent with the mistakes he's made
that he wants to move something all of
us
can learn from it just so happens Conor
was able to do it recently with a big
victory public victory and a very humble
way of him taking it and we'll see
what's gonna happen next but I think
everybody can learn from that because
when money comes when success comes when
Fame comes that's when our character
really gets tested having said that hope
you have a killer week this week take
care everybody bye bye
[Music]